welcome to another developer update I'm
Jeff from the overwatch team we're
really excited to be here today to talk
to you guys about the PTR so first off
for those of you don't know what the PTR
is it stands for public test region or
sometimes public test realm same thing
it's basically a server that players can
go to to test out new upcoming changes
to overwatch the PTR is not always
available it's something that we put up
before we're going to patch the game to
do testing on one thing that I've
noticed that there's some confusion in
the community about is what is the exact
purpose of the PTR and I think a lot of
players assume the PTR only exists so
that players can give feedback on
upcoming changes and while this is a
really important part of what the PTR
does it's not all of what the PTR is
about the most important thing for us
when we patch overwatch to all of the
live service is that the game is stable
and works correctly and there's those
few bugs or crashes or glitches as
possible in the game the PTR really lets
us iron all these issues out we will put
up versions of the game frequently on
the PTR sometimes they'll have a lot of
issues and it allows us to solve them
very quickly so while checking in on how
the players feel about new changes in an
upcoming patch is also very important to
us it's not the primary thing that we're
looking at we're actually looking the
most at the stability of the game and is
it running well is it is it ready to go
live to all of our players so another
question that gets asked very frequently
as how come we don't have the PTR
available for console players and it's
actually kind of a complicated answer
and it mostly has to do with the
logistical challenges of running a game
like overwatch on three platforms as
many of you know the game exists on PC
Xbox one and PlayStation 4
all three of those are unique platforms
on the PC we run on battlenet or the
blizzard platform which is something
that we wholly owned and control here at
blizzard that means that patching it as
frequently as we want is very easy for
us and we incur any risk to our own
system because we're making the changes
we know what we're doing it's our game
if we screw something up we know we're
going to fix it right away it's a little
bit more complicated for the console
platforms because those belong to Sony
and Microsoft and we have a lot of
respect for how solid and protected the
Microsoft and Sony environments are when
it comes to updating for different games
so it's they have their own friends
systems they have their own achievement
or trophy systems they have to be really
careful about games releasing content
onto their platform and causing issues
for their platform so in order for us to
put a version of overwatch onto their
platform we go through a certification
process now something that that was an
issue with our player base early on was
that sometimes PC players would get a
patch and console players would get it
at a different time and there wasn't
always a lot of understanding why this
would happen and the reason that this
would happen is because we could patch
the game on PC as quickly as we wanted
to but we would need to make sure to go
through a certification process with
Sony or Microsoft to be on playstation
or xbox and make sure we weren't
damaging their platforms and in any way
so it caused some times for there to be
a decent one of the ways that we've been
able to patch all platforms
simultaneously so frequently in our
latest updates is because we use the PTR
time on pc to help get through that
certification process on the consoles
and what that means is that we're not
ready to be on the console at the time
that we're doing the PTR experience so
this doesn't mean that
you know never will we ever PTR on
console it just means right now it's
very logistical challenging for us and
part of what's enabling us to have
simultaneous releases of our patches or
as close to simultaneous as possible is
using the PTR time on the pc so i hope
that explains some and alleviates some
of the questions that have come up
around console and PTR so that's sort of
one of the big things that we want to
get out of the way the other question
that comes up a lot is how come there
aren't incentives for me as a player to
come to the PTR so we would love as many
of you to come to the PTR as possible we
are very grateful for those of you who
show up and help us test and provide
feedback on the PTR so all of that is
greatly appreciated for us to put
incentives on the PTR is something we're
looking into so it's not off the table
it's just a little bit complicated so to
give some examples of incentives that
I've seen suggested by the community
that we think are great are you know
maybe if I could get some loop boxes for
coming the PTR or maybe some amount of
my experience from the PTR transfers
over to my live account that would be
really cool those are things we're
looking into the the problem that we
have and hopefully you're somewhat
sympathetic towards it is the those
ideas while very cool would take
development time to implement and right
now we wrestle with you know is it worth
our time is the best way to spend our
time engineering features for the PTR so
players have more incentive or using
that same development time and putting
it towards more of the core features or
content in the game that go out to all
players and up until this point we've
sort of decided well we'd rather you
know spend our engineering time and
resources towards features that
everybody will get to enjoy so hopefully
that makes some sense why there's not a
lot of incentives right now to go to the
PTR for those of you showing up though
it's it's very valuable to us now we are
testing changes on the PTR right now
that go be
on just preparing us for the new patch
there's some balance changes out there
that I know a lot of you are interested
in and I'm not going to go into a lot of
specific details on each of the balance
changes that are out there because by
the time this developer update goes live
we might have already made different
changes so what I'm talking about might
be a little bit of out of date but what
I think is important to understand is
why we're making changes on the PTR to
the heroes we've decided to make changes
to so first up is so Umbra we feel like
sombra is a fantastic hero as I
mentioned the last developer update we
want to be slow with the changes to her
because we we believe she's actually
very powerful and a lot of players
haven't mastered how to play her
correctly yet with that said we do think
she is in need of a little bit of a bump
and we have some ideas to gradually bump
her up until she's in a better spot now
one area where we might not see eye to
eye on with the player base is we don't
expect sombra to ever be sort of a
vicious assassin even though she's in
the offense category we could equally
see her almost being in the support
category we see her more as a disrupter
a backline disrupter than a frontline
flanker or assassin so our goal is not
to make sombra kill people quicker
that's not what we're really interested
in at this time maybe at some future
time we want to steer her in that
direction but right now we're really
believers in that disrupter direction
now road hog is another hero that we're
making changes to and specifically we're
addressing the hook it's important to
know where this the the hook feedback is
coming from so something we hear
frequently is the hook feels really
unfair I didn't like that hook that
happened here watch this video of the
hook we as overwatch developers don't
just come at things from you know we're
not a road hog player and therefore we
don't like being hooked or we are a road
hog player and we don't like how the
hook places certain characters in front
of us we have to come at it from both
sides we have to represent both side
both the victim of Road hogs hook and
road hog himself and when we started to
look at the hook we felt like there were
unfair moments on both sides there were
times as a victim where you get pulled
around a crazy ridiculous corner you
know there's all sorts of videos out
there showing stuff like this and
likewise we felt as road hog players
that there were often times where the
hook placed people in weird spots or you
thought you should have gotten somebody
and you didn't or you got the wrong
person so we want to address all these
things by making the hook feel more
consistent so it doesn't feel like
you're on Dorado and getting hooked 2.2
on illios next up is Deva so diva we
feel like she's just doing too much
right now as you guys know we felt like
she was a little bit underpowered before
we made significant changes to her she
got a big boost to her health pool and
she also was able to move faster while
shooting now something to keep in mind
about diva what we think is very
important about diva is her mobility we
like that she is a tank that gets in and
disrupts and also has ability to get out
when she needs to get out also something
very unique to Deva that no other hero
has is that she didn't does not need to
reload her weapons at all she can keep
continuous fire going as long as she
wants every other hero has a reload
moment which is either a moment for you
to engage or disengage with another hero
and Deva doesn't have that so what what
divas shooting cadence does is it allows
for that range to exist where divas no
longer effective and then diva needs to
readjust with her shift well when she's
too effective with moving and shooting
and diving in on people and her survive
abilities really high add to that the
effectiveness of her defense matrix it's
really hard to come up with a definitive
counter to diva so we wanted to bring
diva back a little bit we need to pull
her back a little bit so she wasn't
great at everything
but the important things to us were the
mobility and that shooting cadence we
feel like defense matrix and her high
health pool already helped with her
survivability but we'll keep a close eye
on diva we care about her as much as a
very passionate community does and if we
get her wrong we will fix her last up
was on ax on ax is a great character I
read a thread today that said hey honest
should be totally reworked we don't
agree with that we think her kit is
really great the way her different
abilities interact with one another we
just want to pull back her overall
healing especially on large coordinated
groups of characters we want to tone
that down a little bit so right now
we're looking into changes with the
grenade we might look at other things
but we don't envision a drastic
reworking of onna we actually think
she's one of our cooler designed heroes
and we have a lot of faith in the design
of the hero but we do think she needs to
be balanced back a little bit but not
anything you know overly dramatic we
don't want to see Anna disappear from
the game so that's not a goal of ours so
that's to address you know why we're
doing the things on the current PTR and
hopefully give you guys a larger idea of
what's going on on the PTR 11 last point
I wanted to make sometimes I hear people
say well what's the point of the PTR you
guys don't make changes based on anyway
and this can be further from the truth
we actually not only read your feedback
very closely on the PTR but we're
looking at the statistics of what
happens on the PTR very frequently most
of the changes that show up on the PTR
wouldn't have existed in the first place
if it weren't for feedback that we're
hearing from you what tends to happen is
that players who are happy with the
changes that we've put on the PTR are
less vocal than those who are not happy
with the changes we have on the PTR so
it's sort of the people who are super
happy and in agreement with
changes that we make are less likely to
spend time going to places like the
forums and saying boy I'm super happy
with everything you're doing keep doing
it and they're more likely to go there
when they disagree with something so
there's usually a little bit of a bias
and the feedback towards the negative
anytime we put up the PTR but that
doesn't mean we're not listening and it
doesn't mean that feedback in both
directions both positive and negative
isn't useful and valid to us I hope all
this makes sense we really appreciate
the time that you guys have spent not
only testing on the PTR but giving even
if you can't be on the PTR giving your
thoughts on the patch notes helping us
make the game better we're going to keep
making improvements in this direction
and we'll keep communicating with you
guys on what changes are coming down the
line thanks for everything
[Music]